at the top of this page subtraction of
functions now just like before I've
given you an f of X and a G of X okay
which one do you think is f of X which
graph how would you describe it the
x-intercept the y-intercept for F should
be minus one that looks like this one
yeah and then and it's steep so that's a
tall gradient too right so cool right so
if we we can actually go ahead and label
that let's call this one y equals f of X
but then you might notice you're like
hold on a second that other one is not G
of X is it right because X plus 2 we
have language to describe this right
it's an increasing function because
great it is is positive positive 1 right
and that's not increasing that's
decreasing right now the reason why I've
given you this graph instead of G of X
is because what we're going to graph is
not f of X plus G of X this is
subtraction of functions we are going to
graph f of X minus G of X ok now there's
a couple of ways to do this but the way
I'm going to encourage you particularly
to start off with is you know how we've
said this many times mrs. Leeson oh
right
many problems in maths what they boil
down to is hey this is really hard
can we turn this hard problem into some
other easier version that we already
know how to solve can we do that right
so I'm going to turn this subtraction
problem into an addition problem watch I
can think of this I'm just going to
encourage you to do this working
alongside on the right-hand side I'm
gonna just write this out just go to
substitute that's what f of X is
takeaway G of X now this is what we call
it a difference of functions right
something takeaway something else but
you can write a difference as a sum as
an addition he's how I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna leave that first thing as G X
minus 1 but instead of saying minus X
plus 2 I'm gonna say it's the same thing
as
- X - 2 do you agree with that
like a 10 take away 3 is the same I'm
going to write it down 10 take away 3 is
the same as 10 plus negative 3 do you
agree with that right adding a negative
is the same as subtracting a positive
okay now the reason why I like this way
of writing it is because it's addition
of functions we already know how to do
this does that make sense so now you can
see over here the graph I've actually
given you this this sloping one right
this is actually minus X minus 2 so this
graph here he's not G of X it's actually
minus G of X do you agree with that
so the real G of X is actually that one
but upside down that's yeah exactly what
I've done I can't you with me I've taken
the opposite sign so what I'm doing here
is I don't like that it's subtraction
right because you can't actually do it
this way you can do it visually but I'm
like I already am good at addition can I
just turn this into an addition problem
and so to turn a subtraction into an
addition what you're doing is you're
adding the opposite of what you were
subtracting okay all right so I'm gonna
it's the same thing okay
so let's have a look at this and let's
apply the same knowledge we had before
I'm gonna do this a little bit faster
though because I think you got the hang
of it from last time right what what two
points are going to be interesting to me
here that I might start with I'm gonna
start with minus 2 y minus 2 why is that
useful what kind of point is it it's an
exodus F thank you then Y value here is
0 the Y value down here is have a look
have a look what's it look like to you
looks like minus 5 right all the way
down here so 0 plus negative 5 what's it
equal to it's just negative 5 BAM so I'm
gonna go through there okay pick another
point for me - what sorry - for where
are you looking what exhale give me an x
value
x equals there's a really easy one have
a look have a look how about half right
I know it's it's a bit of a small axis
here right but the other x intercept you
started with one x intercept let's do
the other one right the other x
intercept is AHA right am I gonna go
above or below just below so I go down
all the way to this guy what does that
look like by the way that looks like y
equals negative two and a half I think
they get two and a half so zero zero
plus negative 2 and 1/2 is negative two
and a half right sob down I'm down here
okay I've got a straight line plus
another straight line what happens when
you add two straight lines together you
get another straight line so I'm just
going to go all the way through this I
think I'm gonna get something like this
whoops
that's a bit wonky I'm gonna try again
sorry that's more like it yeah well
that's why I mean there's this other
technology that's really good that it's
called pencil okay so do you agree I've
gone through both points okay and now
what I'm gonna do just like I did before
is I'm gonna check algebraically if this
matches with what I should be expecting
right so let's do the algebra now right
yeah the answer at the moment we're
focusing is the graph I'm using the
algebra to check my graph right because
later on I'm going to show you graphs
like this and you're going to be like
what what am I supposed to do with that
like there's no quadratic formula for
this there's no nicely but you can graph
this if you're used to thinking like
this okay we'll get to it just not this
particular period okay so let's do the
algebra now just to confirm right what
I'm getting is what is 2x plus negative
X how many X's will I be left with just
a single X then I've got minus 1 and a
minus 2
let's check does this look like my graph
gradient is one gradient is one like so
and y-intercept is minus 3 you can see
it right there
you care with that does it make sense